and here are the nominees for the best  animated feature film brave directed by  Mark Andrews and Brenda Chapman  Frankenweenie directed by Tim Burton  ParaNorman directed by Sam foul and  Chris Butler the pirate and misfits  directed by Peter Lord wreck-it Ralph  directed by rich Moore and the Oscar  goes to  brave Mark Andrews and Brenda Chow I  just happen to be wearing the kilt  I didn't plan any of this I'd like to  thank the Academy for this incredible  honor making a movie has its own story  I'd like to thank John Lasseter Ed  Catmull Jim Morris Andrew Stanton Pete  dr. Brenda Chapman Catherine's raff Ian  for making the making of brave and  exceptional story my wife and my four  kids  Maeve Jack Peyton and Ford I'd like to  give a shout out to my wonderful strong  beautiful daughter  Emma who inspired brave into being so  thank you to her and my husband and our  incredible cast and crew thank you  you  [Music]